[Musica]
belli
il lago
salvo
non lo so
[Musica]
dovrebbero morire tutti ma tra quelli
non vuoi uno scacco propria che stiamo
male perché sa quale incidente moriamo
perché ci ammazzate oh ci spinge a farlo
un motivo incrocio di libertà della
natura nella donna al schifo mano tirato
quindi votare una persona omosessuale
bisessuale trans per della vita c'è
sempre qualcuno del commenta con frasi
tipo finalmente se l'è meritato ho
nemmeno come si fa a essere felice per
morte di qualcuno a volte ora essere
anche così sprezzante
però la morte l'ha vissuta in prima
persona non ci riesco le invidio davvero
le persone che riescono a commentare la
morte altrui con così tanta leggerezza
perché se lo fai
vuol dire che non è mai perso nessuno
malattia amberg rinchiuso in manicomio
va beh sì se per questo è un tempo
bruciano anche le streghe praticavano i
salassi per abbassare la febbre e
utilizzavano interiora di rane e rospi
per distillare pozioni d'amore
wow benvenuti nel 2021 però ragazzi oggi
le macchine sono altre sono il cancro
l'alzheimer il diabete l'elenco è
lunghissimo e colpiscono tutto cuore
polmoni sangue mentre per ogni
centimetro del corpo che è riuscito
immaginare esiste una malattia che lo
distrugge le malattie sono orribili non
permettono alle persone di vivere la
propria vita
anzi la peggiorano la rovinano in alcuni
casi la tolgono
io la mia vita potrei viverla
tranquillamente
eppure forse sono malato forse non
ragione loro
ma la mia malattia per radio e degli
altri
la mia malattia potresti essere tu
orgogliosi spesso ci viene detto
intimato imposto di nasconderci di non
vivere nella nostra vita serenamente
però più delle volte le motivazioni che
ci vengono date su un podio da stronzi
guardare un altra parte se per te non ho
mai visto due sposi uscire da una chiesa
di nascosto
se non riesce a parlare con tuo figlio
problema etoile e poi se non riesce a
spiegare una cosa semplice come la mura
tuo figlio cosa farai quando dovrei
parlargli di odio se ti mette così tanta
ansia parlargli diversità come farai nel
momento in cui dovrai spiegargli che ci
sono bambini che muoiono di fame per via
della guerra ci sono bambini che vengono
amati da piccoli e odiati da grande sono
chiaramente l'omosessualità è contro
natura perché contraddice la leggerà
brani della vita stessi della specie
fatemi capire una cosa tutti quanti voi
che credete in questa tesi del contro
natura come se fosse una motivazione
esistono uomini che asportano borgani da
cadaveri per inserirli dentro ad altre
persone permettere loro di vivere
esistono pratiche che consentono ai
neonati e uscire dalla pancia di una
donna senza passare dal buco che la
natura predisposto per il parto esistono
persone che vivono grazie a de marchi
chi è espletata un fianco chi respira da
una bombola che si alimenta dal naso
perché quando questo succede di state
zitti perché li chiamiamo natura
progresso quando fanno comodo a noi
perché diventano atti abominevoli contro
natura
quando permettono a una persona che sa
tenere non solo un corpo nel quale si
riconosca ma l'unico corpo nel quale
riesco a vivere con maggiore serenità
questa esistenza
capisco ho quindi dovuto del vostro pero
femmina una domanda non capisci o non
vuoi capire perché in quel caso fatti i
cazzi tuoi
se invece ci tieni a capire estrapola
dal contesto ascolta con i quali
aggettivi si definisce una persona che
pronomi usa pensa che ad alcuni puoi
anche chiedere oscar wilde diceva a
volte meglio tacere sembra stupidi che
avrei bocca e togliere ogni dubbio è
così difficile accettare che non potete
capire tutto al primo colpo non ci si
deve preoccupare per gli ammalati di
aids
perché tanto è una perdita di tempo lei
dsa una punizione di dio e gli ammalati
sono i soli responsabili della loro
infezione queste sono le parole di una
donna mentre andava in chiesa
più di un milione di bambini dai 0 ai 9
anni sono positivi al virus della che fu
dio vuole forse la morte dei bambini
cosa fa paura dell'acca i tuoi dell'aids
in modo in cui viene contratto 35
milioni di persone sono morte quindi
perché dio punisce il sesso non protetto
gay o etero che sia seguendo questo
ragionamento di ha ucciso con tra le 70
e le 200 milioni di persone attraverso
una peste nera per punire il semplice
fatto che respirassero sono pessime
meritano di essere discriminati
insultano questo mi ha detto durante un
family day l'omosessualità è peccato
questo veniva detto invece nel vecchio
testamento
nello stesso paragrafo qualche riga
sopra viene descritto come atto
abominevole verdi nutrirsi di crostacei
e 10 doveva proprio avere con chiunque
ingurgita se pesce la masturbazione
peccato il divorzio peccato dire bugie
peccato eppure improvvisamente quando si
tratta di rompere il cazzo su queste
faccende stiamo tutti zitti se credete
davvero e la morte di una persona che ha
semplicemente un gusto diverso al vostro
sia una cosa gradita a dio vuole vedermi
fare quello che ha fatto nesis
quando dei palazzi e delle persone
sospettate di omosessualità con dei
cappucci in testa se per te il normale
dai la natura spinta non importa come
vivrai le scelte che prenderà i motivi
che da rai chi vuole dargli lo sarà
sempre e comunque non puoi parlare con
chi non orecchie non puoi far ragionare
chi non ha un cervello non puoi
emozionare chi non ha un cuore
una cosa però poi farla smette di
sentirti in colpa per ciò che sei
per ciò che desideri per ciò che provi
se loro non si vergognano di odiare
perché tu dovresti vergognarti dal mare